oftentimes
it is possible to find other relevant
information to add to the data set
in sales forecast it's often not
sufficient to use internal data
it is common to collect comparison
information and macroeconomic
information
at other times a data set may contain
duplicate information or columns that
are not informative
as an example sales amount is often kept
in multiple currency in i t
system however only sales amount in one
currency should be used in analysis
otherwise can cause numeric difficulties
in analysis
additional variables can come from
several sources
first data sets are often compiled from
online
and public data sources it is often
possible to collect additional
information from those sources
second it is also possible and sometimes
necessary to create additional variables
from the data
including dummy variables and
transformed variables
and interactions
it is common to create dummy variables
from a single variable
that takes a small number of fixed
values
each of the values is called a category
and the variable
is called a categorical variable we can
create m
minus one dummy variables from a
categorical variable with n categories
where m is an integer each dummy
variable takes the value of 0 or 1
where 1 usually indicates yes and a 0
indicates no
let's look at an example the table on
the left shows three property types
single family home townhouse and condo
so there are three categories in m equal
to three
we can create two dummy variables d1 and
d2
where d1 indicates whether it is a
single family home
and d2 indicates whether it is a
townhouse
both d1 and d2 taking the value 0
indicates a condo
which is neither a single family house
or a townhouse
this procedure of creating dummy
variables can lead to a large number of
dummy variables when there are many
categories for a categorical variable
which can be problematic when
observations for some categories are
we can systematically reduce the number
of categories by combining categories
that are close to each other
going back to the same example in an
original data set
there are many categories other than
single-family home
townhouse and the condo depending on the
purpose of our analysis we may choose to
combine some categories
for example condo koot multi-family and
mobile home can all be mounted to the
others category
in this way we end up using only two
dummy variables
instead of five should we not combine
categories
however be caution that how category
should be combined is not always
straightforward and it should be chosen
carefully
it is common to combine sparse
categories together but it may also
depend on the problem context
as we discussed before we may want to
remove variables from our data set
the first motivation is to simplify
model and analysis
some variables may not contain much
useful information and therefore do not
deserve added complexity for including
them in analysis
there are also cases when some variables
contain the same information
and we should only keep one of them by
removing variables and including a
smaller set of variables
we end up with more parsimonious models
which also tend to be easier to
interpret
note that some methods do not work well
when the distribution for a variable
is degenerate meaning that the variable
only takes a single value
variables with degenerate distributions
have to be removed for better
performance
a variable with degenerative
distribution is also called a zero
variance variable in exploratory data
analysis
for example if everybody in a high
school class are born in the same year
then the first year is a zero variance
variable and is not a relevant variable
in analysis
including it may cause numeric
difficulties
it is more common to have near-zero
variance variables
where only a very small portion of the
data takes a different value if all
students in the class are born in the
same year except one student
then the first year is a variable with
near zero variance
keeping zero variable or near zero
variance variables can cause cardinality
issues in regression analysis
where coefficient estimates can change
erratically when there are small changes
to the data
such behavior is clearly undesirable